nice safe I love you guys I cannot wait
for you to be a part of our big day but
any wedding dates you want us to bring
dates to a wedding are you at your same
who's gonna maintain the booze luge yeah
if it's not clean it's terrible
seriously I thought I got herpes one
time to loosen it we're fun dudes with a
blue skies at the family event will
shape up for you Jeannie we gotta find
the right girls for this this is for
Jeannie where do we even go what we're
about to do something awesome
Mike and Dave Stangl are looking for
dates for their sisters wedding in
Hawaii those bags are gonna take us
shuttle life we're looking for girls
that our mom and our sister would like
we're gonna look respectable as [ __ ]
it's all part of the plan
ma'am I'm not trying to fill up your
breasts my hero save your life
grandma meet Alice she's super smart I
manage a hedge fund Wow
we had yet we had it hard Tatiana she's
a schoolteacher Adult Swim Jeannie I am
proud to introduce our wedding dates you
guys look great together
yeah well be so tiny he's so big take
all that oh who are these girls
9 a.m. who wakes fakes are there most
right there oh yeah that skank wanna hit
stowing down they lied to us to get a
free trip to Hawaii
[ __ ]
it looks like a fucked-up waffle like a
waffle that the chef would just go where
we're throwing that away [ __ ]
you trippin Dave I'll be honest with you
I can't continue where this horse what
it's those girls the girls are problem
you are the bent penguin the soles meet
hold me what's next I'm gonna walk in on
mom give it a push pop what's the push
pop it's a sexual term that I just made
up what's a push pop familia turn off
guitar all apps in metal ties without
each most a casket so hotel over Fester
I date McVeigh